monsieur pupponi bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france
un attentat violent à cause d'un cours
sur la liberté d'expression lors duquel
samuel pâtit avait montré des
caricatures de mahomet est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la religion a envahi
définitivement l'école au point qu'on
puisse plus enseigner la laïcité et la
liberté d'expression oui ça fait
longtemps
ça fait longtemps que des réseaux
proches de l'islam radical ont investi
l'école publique revendique dans l'école
publique et sont très vigilants à chaque
fois qu'ils considèrent que la place des
musulmans n'est pas respectée ce n'est
pas nouveau ça fait des années qu'un
certain nombre d'acteurs publics comme
moi ou d'autres le dénonçons et nous
avons découvert la france a découvert
avec l'horreur de cet assassinat du
professeur que malheureusement la
réalité était bien là vous êtes vous
même un ancien élu local vous avez déjà
été confronté à des problèmes liés à la
laïcité à l'école
bien sûr j'étais maire de sarcelles
quand up nous avions organisé une
semaine de découverte les enfants
partaient raccompagné à la fin du séjour
comme tradition la tradition le veut il
y avait une petite soirée organisée pour
les enfants et à l'occasion d'une de ces
soirées un enfant de 9 ans a interdit
aux enseignants et aux autres enfants
d'écouter de la musique au motif que ça
allait lui salir les oreilles ils
voulaient des cotons-tiges qu'il allait
se transformer en porc et qu'il n'avait
pas droit d'écouter cette musique bref
c'est hélas un peu le vent de panique
des enfants pleuraient et les
enseignants ont annulé la soirée et le
lendemain lorsque les enfants sont
revenus du séjour nous avons convoqué la
mère de famille qui a fait ciel être
qu'être surprise mais mais le même
enfant dix jours plus tard recommencer à
peu près le même scène mais en visitant
le louvre avec son école en considérant
qu'ils n'avaient pas voir des statuts nu
oui bien sûr cette présence là d'un
certain nombre d'enfants liés à l'islam
indique l'amf très rigoriste et de plus
en plus fréquents et souvent les parents
viennent en soutien de ses enfants pour
dénoncer le fait que l'école les
obligerait à voir par exemple des
statuts ou écouter de la musique
justement en 2004 rapport avait été
remis au premier ministre
l'époque françois fillon un rapport
alarmant sur les signes religieux à
l'école jean pierre robin celui qui a
piloté cette enquête a accusé françois
fillon de l'avoir enterrée qu'est-ce qui
a évolué depuis cette date
alors où on a pris en compte tous les
coins de la cité mais globalement
l'éducation nationale laisse les
enseignants et parfois les élus un peu
tout seul se débrouiller comme ils
peuvent
on essaye sur le terrain de régler les
problèmes
le problème de la cantine à la loupe add
minutes puis de substitution le voile
pas le voile les mères de familles qui
accompagnent voilà on se débrouille
comme on peut localement et c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas autre cas localement les
enseignants font ce qu'ils peuvent les
aider et les représentants de
l'éducation nationale au niveau local
les chefs d'établissements les
enseignants sont exemplaires
moi je n'ai jamais vraiment trouvé au
niveau départemental au niveau du
rectorat
un réel soutien en tout cas ils ne le
font pas avec les élus voilà peut-être
que l'éducation nationale a voulu penser
régler le problème tout seul en créant
des structures liées à la licité et
c'est important mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils comprennent que si l'école est
attaqué c'est la république est attaquée
et c'est tous ensemble que nous devons y
arriver ce ne sont pas que des
structures d'éducation nationale qui
pourront apporter la solution
à propos des caricatures de mahomet en
2015 et professeurs avaient dû discuter
attentats de servier avec leurs élèves
des élèves qui ont parfois tenu des
propos assez choquant comment est-ce que
l'on peut discuter de ces questions avec
des enfants il faut mais face à se
prépare il faut faire attention que
derrière n'y ait pas des réseaux
djihadistes un radical qui vont utiliser
tout ça moi ce que je retiens du drame
du champ de levin c'est justement que on
a laissé la chef d'établissement et
l'enseignant seul en face de gens qui
sont très expérimentés dans la lutte
politique dans la lutte liées à l'islam
radical
des prédicateurs qui sont venus et ils
savent très très bien manipuler les
réseaux sociaux ce n'est pas la
responsabilité d'un chef d'établissement
ou d'un enseignant d'être confronté à
ces gens là il faut qu'ils les
structures qui les défendent et qu'il
est qu'il qui empêche ces gens là vont
rentrer dans l'école et l'ont si bien
sûr qu'il faut continuer à montrer les
caricatures bien sûr qu'il faut
continuer à parler de la cité mais il
faut le faire en prenant toutes les
précautions et si on sent que derrière
les réseaux sont actifs pour venir s'y
opposer il faut que des structures
dédiées viennent s'opposer à céret
il ne pas laisser les enseignants ou
l'établissement seul devant ces réseaux
est ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui
comme réponse concrète de la part du
gouvernement
écoutez vous verra la loi moi je sais je
pense que ce que fait une mise de
l'intérieur là est une bonne chose il
fallait réagir mais après ce que
j'attends c'est de la réaction globale
des institutions sur la durée il faut
prendre des mesures maintenant bien sûr
symboliquement c'est important mais la
france mettra du temps la république
mettra du temps est apte à combattre ses
adversaires donc ça sera dans la durée
dans la conviction qui sera la nôtre
dans l'application globale de toutes les
institutions républicaines quel que soit
leur niveau de tous les fonctionnaires
de tous les citoyens que nous arriverons
à gagner donc nous sommes partis pour un
temps très long il faudra que l'on soit
solidaire
il faudra que l'on souhaite déterminer
si nous le sommes alors nous pouvons
arriver à vaincre et la république
vaincra si malheureusement nous
continuons à être désuni comme nous
sommes pas suffisamment volontaire
allant de l'adversaire risque le gagner
merci beaucoup
françois compagne et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
maire ancien maire pardon de sarcelles
et député du val d'oise